you make everyday feel like
it's christmas was that the plan all
along for the jonas brothers to get in
the mix of things
it wasn't actually uh sean levy
who's the executive producer of the show
he was backstage at one of our shows
basically what we talked about that
night over glass tequila is what
became the cameo
the eight episode holiday rom-com series
is all about a guy and a girl
and a red notebook they write back and
forth and send each other out on
ridiculous dares
if you want to know more about me you'll
have to earn it with a
dare nick gives the duo love advice on
the show and
in real life he's been soaking up the
extra time at home with life priyanka
chopra it's hard to find
the silver lining in all this but i
think we we have to
lose our minds the biggest upside of all
this has been that time at home which
me and free wouldn't have had also
lifting nick's spirits
becoming an uncle again nick have you
been able to gush over that new sweet
baby miss willa
i have and it's you know joe and
sophie's thing to speak about or not but
she's uh
she's she's the best that tennis brother
joy
is so real and nick proved he is the
best when he took time out of her
interview last month
to brighten the day of one of my
co-workers simone
girlfriend is a huge jonas brothers fan
she has no idea that i'm zooming with
you right now
so might i have her come in and
surprise for her hey simone
wait is this real
i think so i'm pretty sure it's real how
you doing
we go together i have to just ask you
yes to go on tour again please because
that was the greatest time of my life
greatest time of my life too when we're
able to do so
in a safe way we will be back out on the
[Music]
road